le lycée hôtelier à guyancourt une
nouvelle fois dans la lumière il
accueille aujourd'hui et demain le
concours du club des directeurs de la
restauration et d'exploitation en france
les candidats ont à peine une vingtaine
d'années il se destine à l'hôtellerie de
luxe mélanie poker
c'est un client mécontent ces demandes
n'ont pas été respectées en face de lui
une candidate qui doit résoudre la
situation
c'est une des épreuves de la finale du
trophée du club des directeurs de la
restauration et d'exploitation c'est
pluridisciplinaire c'est destiné aux
étudiants de bts et de licence des
écoles hôtelières françaises et
monégasque et s'est diffusée sur le
territoire national chaque année sous
forme d'une étude de cas les sélections
se font sur la base d'un dossier
l'objectif avant tout et pédagogique il
s'agit de transmettre le goût et l'envié
de faire ce métier qui est un métier
très particulier et aussi pour nous
c'est une occasion de dénicher des
véritables talents dix candidats sont en
lice dans cette finale à venus de toute
la france mathias guilliers est au lycée
de saint quentin en yvelines pour se
qualifier il a travaillé plus de 300 ha
en dehors de ces études c'est un travail
quotidien ces deux à trois heures
quotidien c'est les week-ends entiers
des vacances parfois des nuits pour
pouvoir mener le projet à long terme et
puis pour voir faire en sorte qu'il
ressemble à ce qu'on souhaite juste
l'envié la passion de pouvoir apprendre
plus de pouvoir travailler dans le bon
endroit avec un savoir-faire réel
savoir-faire de de tous les métiers la
restauration le service la direction la
cuisine dix épreuves attendre les
candidats le nom du vainqueur sera connu
vendredi 17 mars dans la soirée